I'm coaster drinker I work as a group
leader at the Sanger Institute in
Cambridge my group is interested in
understanding how genetic variants
modulate the immune system and in
particular how they make the immune
system attack your own body so that
leads to the autoimmune diseases such as
type 1 diabetes or celiac disease gluten
intolerance I have a web lab background
that's what I did during my master
studies and then I went through my PhD I
was slowly understanding that I really
liked that computational part of of the
research so for my next step for my
postdoc I decided to make it really
purely computational so I spent two
years developing statistical methods but
at that point also I've realized that
I'm actually missing that the wet lab
component of it and that's really what
brings me here and to my group where we
have both the wet lab and the dry lab
component really integrated that means
that we can have research questions and
address them by generating our own data
and then analyzing it ourselves in the
web lab we're trying to understand how
the immune cells function and so for
that we are isolating specific immune
cell types and then we're stimulating
them to see how they respond and then in
order to measure that response on the
molecular level we perform different
genomic assays and the output of those
asses or the data that we generate in
the wet lab is then analyzed in the dry
lab
a lot of the computational work really
involves getting rid of the background
noise from the data the experimental
noise and fishing out that biological
signal that is important to us and
focusing on that I always get really
very excited when Natalia comes in with
some results and I want to know how she
did it
what did she change what things are
working what things are not working how
are we gonna change them it's the
process itself and then the satisfaction
when you get something to work it's
definitely one of the best parts about
being the scientist this moment when you
go yes it worked oh yes I found out
something new it's amazing I've never
had a master plan I never aim to be here
I always followed my passion my interest
and the science that made me excited I
never planned to do a PhD or become a
geneticist so I don't know where I'm
gonna be in the future but I'm also not
worried about that because I'm just
gonna keep on following the research
that makes me really excited